how much do you pay a personal trainer
for a training session how much do you
pay somebody to help you fix your sales
process a lot more for the guy to help
you fix your sales process that was my
most valuable skill that I had developed
and so that was the one I traded with
most often I could walk into a company I
already went through your entire funnel
I already saw your follow-up sequences I
hopped on the phone with one of your
guys when you do that do you think the
person whose business you did that for
will not try and offer to help you in
some way of course they will and if
you're like dude I don't know how to run
YouTube ads they're like dude whatever
you need I've got you that's how you
provide value to people